[Music]
on this tuesday night a new spike in
covid 19 cases
and a new school year this week i think
is is a really critical week
the warnings and the unprecedented
stress for students
if there's too much anxiety child's not
going to learn as one province
reimposes some restrictions fast-moving
fires
ripped through california it was pretty
scary the record
shattered and the rescues deteriorating
relations between beijing and the west
the journalists who feared becoming
political pawns
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is september 8th that means we've
been in this pandemic for seven months
now
and it means fall and winter are
approaching covid19 is going
nowhere in some parts of canada the
virus is now spreading faster than it
was over the summer
and that has set off alarm bells as
students head back to school canada's
top doctor is urging canadians to get
back to public health basics although
canada is striving to maintain a slow
burn
the average daily case counts has been
increasing in recent days
this is concerning now is not the time
for complacency
new infections were reported across
canada today though the areas of
greatest concern
are the four biggest provinces british
columbia alberta
ontario and quebec today there were 83
new cases in bc 157 in alberta
163 in quebec and 185
in ontario and in ontario officials are
so concerned about the uptick in cases
they've caused any further easing of
restrictions
for four weeks the health minister says
that means no changes to the size of
social circles or public gatherings
allowed in ontario
today the premier pleaded again for
people to be responsible
and report bad behavior if they see it
because it's pretty simple just follow
the guidelines don't have these big
parties
don't have these big family gatherings
it is simple
and i encourage the neighbors if you
hear the big parties call the police and
i'm asking the police
go in there and lay charges very very
simple
we have to start putting the hammer down
on people that don't want to follow
protocols and guidelines
the message is play by the rules now
because if you don't tighter public
health restrictions will return
in bc that's happening now provincial
health officer dr bonnie henry has
ordered all night clubs and banquet
halls to close immediately
bars and restaurants can no longer serve
alcohol after 10 pm
and they must close by 11. as we get
back to
to work for many people and back to
school for many people
it is the time for all of us to cut back
on our social interactions there are
going to be challenges ahead
we have two reports tonight beginning
with eric sorenson
it's a convergence that is worrying
public health officials and governments
across the country
just as schools are reopening covert 19
case numbers are rising
in ontario close to 400 new cases the
last two days
on this the first day of school for many
young ontarians across the province
we need to do everything we can to limit
the spread of covet 19.
but after a spring of near total
lockdown and a summer of greater social
interaction
now comes a new test can children return
to classrooms
and not create a second wave in the
pandemic school can be a source of
transmission
and i think that our bigger concern also
is looking at the colder months
where people are going to tend to huddle
indoors and all these things can
contribute to increased transmission
already national numbers are rising
particularly in the west british
columbia reported an average of fewer
than 20 cases per day from mid-may to
mid-july
it's risen to an average of about 80
cases a day in late august early
september
the graph shows a similar rise in cases
in alberta manitoba saw a recent burst
in case numbers
ontario and quebec are rising but not as
dramatically as in the west
on the east coast case numbers remain
low nova scotia for example
averaged less than one case per day for
weeks the overall national pictures
the third week of august an average of
390 reported cases per day across the
country
the following week 435 cases per day
into the first week of september
an average of 545 cases daily a 25
increase over the week before this week
i think is is a really critical
week and so for sure next week because
then you would have had
some idea of what happens when you go
back to school so the next couple of
weeks
is is two weeks of
careful vigilance one big advantage in
dealing with covet 19 now
it's being monitored much more
effectively than it was last march
because we are looking at the numbers
and the trends so closely we're actually
seeing the wave
as it's developing and that way we can
do more focused lockdown focused
interventions to try to
keep these small fires from becoming a
big one young people are less likely to
get seriously ill from covet 19
but it is a massive social and
epidemiological experiment
putting children back in schools without
putting themselves or other more
vulnerable canadians
at risk eric sorenson global news
toronto
are anxiety on the first day of school
is normal but in this new normal nothing
is as it was
it's a whole other world in there it's
been six months since students last saw
the inside of a classroom
in pickering ontario the young's
practice what to do in lieu of hugging
their friends
had long talks about staying safe and
the importance of masks
it's going to be hard because i'm going
to have to like maybe go to the side and
do this
because i might not be able to breathe
and it's going to be very hard to to
just just wear a mask in school
but she says she'll do it because we've
seen a flurry of cases at schools across
the country
after a single positive test 100
students were sent home
from an edmonton high school and in
ottawa 200 staff and students are now in
quarantine
after possibly being exposed to a number
of cases on school buses
while concerning health officials say
neither story is unexpected
a big danger right now they warn is
overreacting and creating anxiety for
our kids
when we know that students are too
anxious when um then
learning stops the the brain actually
starts to reconfigure itself into the
fight or flight
if there's too much anxiety child's not
going to learn they look very
distracted all the time or they become
very
drawn in they can become very freeze
very quiet
balancing safety and education has never
been more complicated
and it all starts with how we drop our
kids off at school
mike drolik global news toronto an
independent review
has been ordered into canada's early
pandemic warning system
employees including scientists inside
the public health agency
told the globe and mail their warnings
were ignored just months before the
pandemic was declared
michael couture has been digging into
this mike what have you discovered
well donna not only is there an
independent review but global news has
learned the auditor general
is also asking questions about the
global public health intelligence
network or
gfin as it's known now dr theresa tam
welcomes the review
but says the system is still working i
got
my email from g finn you know
as soon as they noticed something which
was around the
december the 31st january 1st
time frame that was the date the world
woke up to a cluster of cases in wuhan
china
health officials in canada saw reports
over a system
called the global public health
intelligence network
unlike in the past it didn't come
through email
as an alert it's sending out the alerts
as i understand it were stopped in may
of
2019. dr ronald saint john helped create
g
finn more than 20 years ago to help
alert canadian officials
to health issues across the globe he got
the same email as dr
tam and a number of other messages but
there was no
health alert if the information just
lies there well then the subscriber can
come in and look
and make some decisions but it's not the
same as issuing an emergency alert
to all the subscribers that there's
something they should pay attention to
health minister patty haidu calls the
system critical to identifying and
monitoring
outbreaks in a statement her
spokesperson added
this independent review is an important
step in restoring gfin
and ensuring that it can continue its
valuable contributions to public health
in canada
and around the world i think the review
will look at
what actually happened to
those specific alerts as opposed to the
regular daily
reports that's not good enough according
to the conservative health critic
a protracted internal investigation
with no end date no potential
repercussions
no promise to make this public is
completely unacceptable
a spokesperson for the health minister
told global news they plan
to have the review complete and the
final report in the hands of the
minister
within the next six months donna all
right mike locateur in ottawa thanks
in quebec a number of politicians are in
self-isolation after meeting with a
mayor who tested positive for covid19
sylvie param mayor of the city of
longgay says she began to experience
symptoms last friday after several days
of meetings
at least four members of the quebec
government including the transport and
justice ministers plus the mayors of
montreal and laval are also
in self-isolation now awaiting test
results
quebec has unveiled a new kovid 19 alert
system to help people stay informed
it's a color-coded system it has four
levels and is region specific
green the lowest level calls for
vigilance and basic measures like
wearing masks
yellow level 2 adds inspections and
crowd control to enforce physical
distancing
orange is a moderate alert higher risk
activities are restricted or prohibited
and red level four is when the risk
cannot be sufficiently contained
and maximum measures are applied like a
ban on non-essential activities
right now four regions of quebec are in
the yellow zone
everywhere else is in the green the
lowest level
and in ottawa the new federal
conservative leader has unveiled what he
calls a government
in waiting erin o'toole has chosen the
mps who will form the party's shadow
cabinet
former leader andrew scheer has made the
cut the question is what will aaron
o'toole offer canadians in terms of
leadership and policies that is
different from shear
and that will get the conservatives
elected in the next federal election
speculation about a possible fall
election is still flying around ottawa
mercedes stephenson our ottawa bureau
chief is with me
mercedes start with aaron o'toole's team
and his strategy
well donna as you know in anything but
especially in politics
having the right people in the right
places is so important for the
conservatives
as they try to give themselves a
pre-election makeover
hoping to make themselves more appealing
to voters you mentioned that former
leader
andrew scheer managed to stay on he got
a pretty high
profile portfolio that will be key in
the pandemic recovery
and that's infrastructure that will also
see him facing off
against catherine mckenna a couple of
other key names on the list that our
viewers will likely recognize
pierre pauliev stays on as the finance
critic he's been a strong voice for the
opposition
leading the charge on the we controversy
michelle rempel
garner also in there she'd been shut out
by the sheer camp
she's back now resurging into the high
profile health portfolio
which obviously will be very important
during this pandemic and aaron o'toole
himself takes on the role of
middle-class prosperity which sends you
a signal
now conservative sources say the new
leader is already trying to plot out a
very different tone and vision for the
conservative party
one that they hope will make it hard for
the liberals to pigeonhole them
as going into austerity during a
pandemic o'toole is already pushing a
new message
one focused on helping labor and holding
big corporations accountable
a very different sort of message than we
heard from the conservative party before
and a sign that they are preparing to
broaden the tent as the polls say they
must do
to win especially in ontario mercedes i
think only the block quebecois said they
want a fall election
i think that's right so why are people
still talking about it as a possibility
well that's a great question donna
because it almost becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy at some point
and that is the concern of some of us
who cover politics here in ottawa
but while we only have the block
quebecois saying they definitely want
one you're seeing a lot of people
hedging bets the government has to
really
balance here finding opportunity without
seeming
opportunist for some of the more drastic
changes
that they're wanting to make take a
listen to this you're not wanting to be
seen
as trying to use this for a great
political experiment
but as a time to perhaps introduce
something that is actually going to
improve the lives of canadians canadians
aren't going to have a lot of patience
sometimes the devil is in the details
and while the ndp is likely to support
the government on some of those big
ticket programs donna
the question will be how they're
implemented as ndp strategist carl
belanger told us today
the key will be how to implement those
things and when
and how fast and with uh with how much
money and those are the details that
often
uh you know bring bring down governments
because
if actions if words are not followed by
action you are
in for some trouble and donna we'll see
if there'll be a choice between two
solitudes here in the
potential coming election for canadians
as we continue to talk about it still
no end in sight for that speculation
donna okay well i long for the
speculation to end but anyway thanks
mercedes i
appreciate that wildfires are burning on
the west coast and a poor air quality
advisory is in effect for parts of bc
choked by smoke from fires
in washington state on vancouver island
thick smoke is blanketing the southern
tip
including the city of victoria residents
are being asked to avoid strenuous
activities outdoors
the same goes for people in the southern
interior of bc
this is what soyuz looked like yesterday
and this is what it looks like today
in california 25 major wildfires are
burning more than 800
000 hectares have burned a new record
and there are still four months to go
in the fire season
today the national guard rescued at
least 150 people from the sierra
national forest
more helicopters have been sent to save
others trapped by the huge
creek fire in new york state the police
chief and other high-ranking officials
in rochester say they're retiring
they've come under scrutiny after the
death of daniel prude an
african-american man
he died in march days after being pinned
to the ground by officers
police chief lauren singletary resigned
today after six days of protests
back in march daniel prude who was naked
and unarmed stopped breathing after
being placed in a spit hood and pinned
to the pavement for two minutes
he died seven days later at the time
police claimed he'd suffered a drug
overdose
the death sparked outrage last week and
relatives released body cam video
showing how the arrest took place
the medical examiner has ruled his death
a homicide
a five-day diplomatic dust-up coming up
the western reporters caught in the
middle
and relieved to be out of china
two australian reporters are back on
home soil tonight after a tense five-day
diplomatic standoff in china
the men were questioned by chinese
police about the detention of another
australian journalist who is now being
held in beijing
on national security grounds the story
is familiar to canadians the two
michaels michael kovrig and michael
spavor
still languish in a chinese jail facing
similar charges
all of it a low point in relations
between china
and the west as redmond shannon reports
journalist mike smith back in australia
and
clearly relieved did you feel threatened
at all when you were over there
a little bit yes it was a complicated
experience
smith and bill bertles had been the last
two australian journalists
in china working for australian media
outlets
and then last week australian officials
advised them to leave as soon as
possible
but before they could do so they knock
on the door to say
uh we are from the beijing department of
the national security bureau
and we're here to tell you that you are
involved in a case the chinese officials
wanted to speak to the men about the
news anchor
chung lei she's an australian citizen
who was working in beijing for a
state-controlled television network
but was detained last month on national
security grounds
we're kind of odd people to
interview or interrogate if it was
really just about that case
so it sort of felt to me like the whole
episode was about harassment
both men went to their nearest
australian consulates chinese officials
interview them
there before allowing them to fly home
the detention of lay bears some
similarities with the arrests of
canadians michael coverig and michael
spavor almost
two years ago their cases ramped up
tensions between
china and the west following canada's
detention of huawei executive
mong mong zhou at the request of
american authorities
then there was the decision by australia
and then by others to ban huawei from
being part of
5g mobile networks although canada has
yet to do so explicitly
additionally australia angered beijing
by pushing for an international
investigation
into the origin of kobe 19.
a beijing spokesman said tuesday as long
as foreign journalists abide by the law
there is no need to worry global affairs
canada says
it doesn't keep track of the number of
canadian journalists working for
canadian media outlets in china
but says it advises a high degree of
caution due to
arbitrary enforcement of local laws
redmond shannon global news
london confessing to atrocities still
ahead two men who say their soldiers
speak out
stunning development in the pursuit of
justice for the victims of killings in
myanmar and attempts to eradicate
rohingya muslims
two men believed to be deserters from
myanmar's army have admitted in a video
confession to taking part in what canada
and other countries call
genocide the video has not been released
to the public but these are images from
it
two men who say they were soldiers
confessing to being involved in horrific
acts of violence against myanmar's
rohingya muslim minority
the video has been analyzed by fortify
rights a human rights organization
it says the men confessed to taking part
in atrocities and
based on their detailed accounts has
determined they were directly involved
in the deaths of more than 180 men
women and children as well as other
crimes including rape
they also named six senior commanders
who were giving orders
and those orders were according to their
testimony
orders to commit genocide they were
being ordered to
quote unquote quote unquote exterminate
all rohingya
global news cannot verify their claims
but fortify wright says the details
align with
other accounts of survivors who fled to
bangladesh
by the hundreds of thousands three years
ago bob ray who served as canada's
special envoy to myanmar before becoming
ambassador to the un
says there will be consequences for the
two men and their confessions could be
crucial
in linking the atrocities to myanmar's
military strategy
we are involved in a very painstaking
brick-by-brick step-by-step
effort to get the people who are
responsible
into court but the reality is
there's nowhere to hide there are two
cases against myanmar one at the
international criminal court
and another at the international court
of justice last week canada joined the
netherlands in signaling its intent to
intervene in the second case
justice won't be quick and the
persecution of the rohingya
continues and there are upwards of 600
thousand still in rakhine state
they are denied the right to freedom of
movement they're essentially living in
an open-air prison
in apartheid system smith is hopeful of
former soldiers admissions will help
push cases against myanmar
forward it is a massive crack
in myanmar's armor of impunity
fortify wright says the two men have
been taken into protective custody in
the hague
where they could be tried by the
international criminal court
an icc spokesperson would not confirm
that to global news
or any other details citing
confidentiality
and the fact the case is ongoing
up next a new helmet could be handy for
health workers
necessity is the mother of invention and
some students in vietnam have come up
with a prototype of a helmet to protect
frontline workers from covid19 the
designers say it will bring some small
comforts
to those who have to wear protective
gear for hours it has an air purifying
respirator a built-in glove to let you
scratch your nose there's even a
compartment to store snacks
the students are already working with a
company to get it mass produced
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada
is hamilton township ontario thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you